it's no secret that CEOs are paid it
really well but in most cases the vast
majority if not their entire
compensation is paid out in stock for
instance sundar Pichai gets 242 million
dollars in compensation per year but
only two million dollars of that is in
cash or less than a 1% of course that's
a great cash salary but nowhere near his
total compensation so when he is looking
to sell
how would he go about selling billions
of dollars worth of stock without
crashing off that stock
[Music]
well starting off companies and their
founders are well aware of this issue
and this is why the user process of
stock vesting
it's not to CEOs and high-level
executives they need to consider
thousands of engineers and managers can
cost just as much damage oftentimes
engineers and managers are offered stock
bonuses of ten to twenty thousand
dollars and over several years these
guys generally rack up stock holdings
well into six figures going back to
Google as an example they have over
ninety eight thousand employees of which
most are well-paid managers and
engineers alphabets median salary itself
is two hundred and forty six thousand
dollars so we can assume that most of
their employees do get stock
compensation so even if just ten percent
of their workforce decides to cash out
this could mean billions of dollars of
stock reaching the market and this is
where stock vesting comes into play
stock vesting is basically a restriction
to selling stock too quickly there are
two main types of stock vesting which
are time-based vesting and milestone
based vesting time-based vesting is the
most common type used by companies
time-based vesting is essentially what
it sounds like companies set a minimum
time requirement before an employee is
actually able to sell the stock and this
is also generally contingent on
employees still working at the company
at the time for the average employee and
management this is usually just one year
however for CEOs and executives the time
period is generally four to five years
companies basically divide the total
stock compensation by the vesting time
and create what is known as a vesting
cliff this is just a graph that
showcases when employees are actually
able to sell their stock and how much of
it if one is to resign during this
window they will not get the remainder
of the stock as this will be reclaimed
by the company so whenever you see a
CEOs compensation that is generally what
they will realize over the next four to
five years if they stick with the
company and what they are currently
realizing is an average of what they
were earning the past four to five years
moving on let's take a look at milestone
based fasting this is essentially the
same thing as time-based vesting but
instead of the goal being a time period
is generally a market cap for instance
Apple could tell Tim Cook that he can't
sell his shares until Apple's worth two
trillion dollars and finally we have
hybrid vesting which is a combination of
both time-based vesting and Malcolm base
vesting but what is even the purpose of
vesting periods employees that have been
working at a company for several years
can still cause damage by selling pick
volumes and this is especially a threat
when companies are on downfall well the
thing is the vesting time is more for
the company rather than employees the
vesting time period isn't built to
prevent employees from selling shares
too early but rather give companies a
time to be able to afford to buy them
back for big companies the vesting
period is not that big of a deal because
they already have large cash reserves
ready to buy back stock
for instance alphabets net income last
year was thirty four point five billion
dollars so even if sundar pichai were
able to sell his entire 240 million
dollar compensation every year which he
can't but even if he could alphabet
could buy it back for a decimal value of
their net income and this is how
companies prevent executives and
employees from selling billions of
dollars worth of stock and crashing the
stock price companies simply buy back
the stock under the company's name
during periods in which many employees
are cashing out and then they turn
around and hand the stock to next CEO or
next employee or even the same person
the following year so a vesting takes
care of basically 99.9 percent of the
market but there's still a handful of
individuals left to deal with core
founders / founder CEOs people like
Sergey Brin Larry Page Elon Musk Bill
Gates and Jeff Bezos the thing is these
guys are founders and they usually care
about the well-being of the company very
much so
they only liquidate as much as they need
and limit it to well below how much the
market can handle and/or how much the
company can buy back
for instance Jeff Bezos liquidates 1
billion dollars worth of Amazon stock
per year to fund a space company Blue
Origin and since Amazon is worth over 1
trillion dollars this is less than 0.1%
and doesn't harm stock price but yes at
this rate he would tell Jeff Bezos well
over 100 years to liquidate his position
a great example of this is Bill Gates
he's been selling off his shares since
1986 at which point he owned 45% of
Microsoft down to 1% today 1% is still
worth over 10 billion dollars today but
currently Bill Gates is within 10 years
of being able to sell off his entire
Microsoft Holding of course I don't
think yours maximizing how much he could
sell off every single year but
nonetheless for most founders selling
their entire stake would mean decades of
selling if they want avoid hurting stock
prices so most founders will never be
able to realize their full wealth within
our lifetime but this doesn't really
matter as they can liquidate more than
they could spend anyways that's most
founders there are some loose cannons
though that just liquidate their entire
stake in a matter of weeks
for instance Steve Jobs sold his entire
11 percent stake other than one share in
a fit of anger in 1985 after he was
fired from his own company
more recently ubers co-founder Travis
kalanick sold a 2.5 billion dollars
worth or 90% of a stake in just six
weeks
at the end of 2019 he was also author
like Steve Jobs quite recently
anyways generally companies placed
vesting tabs on stocks in order to grow
enough capital to offset employees an
executive selling off stock founders on
the other hand can cause serious damage
but they understandably don't intend to
except for some unique situations in
such scenarios there's up to two other
large stakeholders to buy up as much as
they can to minimize the repercussions
of large-scale liquidation but hey maybe
they should have thought about that
before
Alice ting a founder if you guys thought
this video thoroughly explained how
companies prevent devaluation from too
much liquidation they major drop a like
and consider subscribers see more
questions logically
but until then I'm Hardy and I'll see
you guys on the next one
[Music]